Andthen
and
I want to go there to get Yasmim Araxá my
sister over there in that place over there look
5:40 at night they found her body and they
found four more little there along with
her over there and my brother-in-law and  So far you haven't
found it buried there but at least there
where are those men who are digging
there but they think it's there there we
are waiting to see what you think is
the series sold out and High temperature
throw me that originated responsible for an
insekt Dreams roads  weather weather
draws on Windows Live web cam USB 1
[Music]
And
as I woke up with the rumbles with
agony with the rush there when I
went outside I came across
a part of the house that had collapsed there
when the people from the  The community itself that
came to help tried to help in
every way It stayed there digging and
digging to find the bodies then it
collapsed for the second time
that's when it collapsed for the second time when it
knocked down the neighbor's house the whole
family died then the family died  the father dies the
two children die by force and
Andthen
[Music]
the and 40 years that I've lived here I've never seen
this tragedy, you know, personal payment
that I saw like that
Andthen
[Music]